there's no issue of global point of
importance none that where our nations
are not leading together and we're not
sharing our common values to make things
better
and our conversations today
we continue to build on all that we've
achieved over these past months
we discussed how we can continue to
adapt and upgrade our partnership to
ensure our countries remain at The
Cutting Edge of a rapidly changing world
our economic partnership is enormous
strength and source of strength that
anchors everything that we do together
we want to harness that power to make
sure we're creating good jobs and
supporting working class families in
both our countries
and the growth is shared broadly and no
one gets left behind so today we're
releasing a new plan to equip our
economic partnership for the 21st
century
it outlines how we can enhance our
cooperation to accelerate the clean
energy transition that must take place
and is taking place lead the development
of of emerging Technologies are going to
shape so much of our future
and protect Technologies critical to our
national security
and a key piece of that is working
together to strengthen our critical
mineral Supply chains and to make them
more resilient so we're not depending
any one country to meet our goals
when it came when it comes to technology
that will shape the future like
semiconductors Quantum Computing
artificial intelligence the UK and the
U.S are working together to make sure
they are developed safely and
responsibly and jointly
we're going to do more on joint research
and development to ensure the future
we're building remains and fundamentally
aligned with our value set in both our
countries and we're doing more to
prevent technologies that are are
invented and developed in our countries
from being used
for for military or intelligence
purposes by countries that do not share
our values
today we're also discussed our
unwavering support from the people of
Ukraine
and defend who are defending themselves
against most brutal aggression we've
seen in a long time at the hands of
Russia and Putin the UK and the United
States together with more than 50
partners
have committed historic levels of
security assistance to Ukraine I want to
thank the Prime Minister for a strong
strong leadership contributing
significant amounts of security
assistance and training Ukrainian troops
so they can effectively use the
equipment and ammunition we've
collectively provided
and I'm bringing the world together
later this month to drive support from
Ukraine's long-term economic recovery
you're doing a great deal
so Mr Prime Minister thank you for
making the journey to Washington earlier
this week we marked the 79th anniversary
of D-Day and a timely reminder of a
proud history of our nation's share and
the values the values that we have long
stood together to defend
that's the unshakable foundation of this
special relationship and it is a special
relationship
there's no country closer to us than
Great Britain today as NATO allies
Partners in Innovation as friends in the
shared vision of the future
and the two Nations our two nations are
ready to meet the challenges of our time
and meet them together
and I'm confident the United Kingdom of
the United States will continue to lead
the world toward greater peace
prosperity and security for all
so thank you again Mr Prime Minister